the illustration below shows the graph
of y is a function of X so that's this
graph right over here and then they
start to ask us some questions complete
the sentences based on the graph of the
function so this X is our y axis or
vertical axis horizontal axis is x axis
initially as x increases let's think
about initially so when we start from x
equals 0 and X is increasing what's
happening to Y well Y is decreasing so Y
decreases so as x increases initially Y
decreases the slope of the graph is
equal to blank for all X between x
equals 0 and x equals 3 so x equals 0
and x equals 3 what's the slope well
every time we move one in the x
direction we move down in the y
direction we go negative 1 in the Y
Direction move up 1 in the x direction
we go negative 1 in the Y direction so
our change in Y over our change in X our
change in Y is negative 1 whenever our
change in X is 1 so our change in Y over
our net change in X which is the
definition of slope is negative 1 over 1
so it's negative 1 and we see that every
time x increases by 1 Y decreases by 1
starting at x equals 3 starting is at x
equals 3 blank Y blank as x increases so
starting at x equals 3 Y increases as x
increases as x increases Y is increasing
so Y increases as x increases the slope
of the graph is equal to blank but for X
between 3 & 5 for X between 3 and 5 so
when x increases by 1 Y is increasing by
3 so change in Y is 3 change in X is 1
slope is change in Y over change in X
which is 3 over 1 so the slope here is 3
every time x increases by 1 Y increases
by 3 for X between x equals 0 and x
equals 4 y and let's see we can pick
greater than less than or less than or
equal to greater than or equal to or
equal so for x equals 0 and x equals 4 y
is less than is less than or equal to 0
so it's still less than or equal to 0
and then they say for X between x equals
4 and x equals a
well then why is greater than or equal
to zero so let's make sure that we got
it we didn't make any careless mistakes
here let's check our answer we got it
right